we keep finding a glut of classified
docks and smuts
yes their search at Joe's Place was
belated while Hunter's texts were
x-rated well America in case you were
troubled by the fact that the FBI never
bothered to search President Biden's
place in Rehoboth Beach Delaware for
classified docks you can rest easy
because the deed it's finally done but
it wasn't quite the gun toting kick in
the door by the light of dawn Affair we
saw it Mar-A-Lago and this time they
didn't sniff anyone's shoes or underwear
far from it the doj conducted a planned
search of his beach home I hate that
word rope
anyway translation somebody must have
given them a heads up using standard
procedures and in the interest of
operational security and integrity the
doj said this work was done without
advanced public notice because the only
reason to make a scene is if you're
searching Don's place right
gosh darn it do you know what they found
nothing just like the MRI from Biden's
skull
you know I'm sure none of us saw this
coming and speaking of coming
[Laughter]
the perpetually aroused Hunter
slipped his Legal Assistant thousands of
dollars under the table while the two
were banging each other in 2018 and
2019. in fact the assistant is one of at
least four women who hook hooked up with
Hunter while on his very payroll
including his sister-in-law Haley
her sister
and baby mama London Roberts
for a guy on so many drugs he sure has
amazing endurance
and yeah I said it right he slept with
his sister-in-law and her sister
you know I'm starting to think Hunter is
questionable judgment
but let's be open-minded Joe what do you
think no no no no no no no look come on
man get out of my face come on we FBI
was here we're fully cooperating
fully cooperating
cooperation is funny it makes a cloudy
day sunny makes a bee think of honey
just don't get honey on your hairy legs
say it a million times you never get it
off I told Hunter he won't listen he's
just a kid he doesn't know better hey
look here's the deal
the true story it's not a joke first guy
in the history of the
anyway
he's amazing
Charlie
Hunter is this is clearly the biggest
law you could break in any kind of
employment world but he and please the
employer right oh no and you know
usually when you read about things like
this it's like some gray area where like
somebody's using like some power Dynamic
to get something that's not what's going
on here it's like I will write you I'll
send you oh venmo you 500 for a chat
over and we talk about all of this on
whatever
um these people are sick they're the
sickest people that we have ever had
like in politics and we've had some real
sickos in politics oh yeah but these
people just blow the doors off but I do
think it's kind of funny you know the
FBI had all those pictures from
Mar-A-Lago they don't have any pictures
from the robot that's because they're
all in hazmat suits can you imagine yeah
go tossing Hunter Biden's bedroom oh my
God
oh the things you would find
floors looking under his bed oh geez cat
what do you want to talk about documents
or Hunter
I mean either one is fine yes uh I came
prepared yes
um okay just 100 just I quickly just
want to say something about him which is
that for like the whole point of like a
sex worker is that you hire her because
then the only thing that impacts is your
bank account right and you don't have to
see her again or deal with it in real
life he's like I'm gonna get a sex
worker who's also my assistant I have to
see every day that's like that's dumb it
is um and then what also's dumb is this
big fake pretend thing of Biden's being
transparent when if they were being
transparent they wouldn't have hidden it
until the media finally talked about it
and then when they did talk about it
they hid the other stuff that they
thought the media didn't know about yet
so it's a big joke and I don't know how
we continue to allow them to say so
that's far more expensive to me than
sexting with the sex one you don't pay a
prostitute to sleep with you you pay her
to leave him that's what chef says in
South Park yeah
thank you
Jamie um I learned everything about life
from him
Jamie uh I would try to work a joke
about how Hunter has a better life than
you but we already know that so care to
comment on anything else I was just I'm
really thinking about that you pay a
prostitute to leave not to have sex with
you I can't stop thinking about it
could I recommend have her sleep with
you first though yes
because then she leaves you like ah
um
you know what I know people hate Hunter
Biden Greg as a comedian he's the gift
that keeps on giving it's it's
unbelievable and I do have these moments
where I feel bad for Joe Biden like as a
dad I feel bad because you know like
when I think you know like there was a
time when Hunter was like a little kid
and Joe was teaching him how to fall off
a bike you know and um
yeah
they busted him hardly I guess his um
account his credit card account was
flagged for suspicious activity when he
didn't hire a prostitute within 24 hours
and um same thing happens when uh Brian
stealth Brian stelter buys fruit yeah
um
you know my last thing is like wasn't it
probably fun for Biden to go through
like a search of his own home because
that's what he does every day
oh wow you know he's walking around
going like they're my that's where the
guest bathroom is
oh my god I've been using my pants
[Laughter]
very good yeah you know to what you're
saying I'm like
Biden has a think tank isn't that like a
contradiction of terms like what is he
thinking about in his Think Tank yeah
who is doing the thinking in the think
tank
what are the issues and who a tank is
he's going to hire Corn Pop to over see
the Lifeguard tank at the thing what is
the thing what was he doing in the think
tank yeah it's a great question you know
what he was he was laundering money
that's what he was by the way when you
pay assistant for sex is that tax
deductible no no thank you for asking me
like I but at the end
you were leading with this you know
every day ever since Lou Dobbs left I
can only ask you these questions oh man
is it an exception because he's like his
own boss is that that's what I'm saying
he's because you're on your if you own
your own business you can sexually
harass yeah I heard though that they're
into it though I mean it's not
harassment but then he was face wasn't
under Brian setting of FaceTime calls
yes to have sex on the FaceTime is he
doing Zoom calls with the sisters no
because you know why they said not on my
face time
I think we should go after that
I heard he sends him to HR but it's just
him in a porn mustache
all right now we're gonna go I'm
sweating
it's the left versus the right and a
pledge of allegiance fight
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else